it gets pretty lonely out here
[Music]
I lead to regain the memories that the
cree took for me
you are Carol Danvers the most powerful
person I knew way before you could shoot
fire from your fists I get in trouble
for that I can see that about you
but what happens when
I'm finally set free
[Music]
I'll be back before you know it
Lieutenant trouble
when you left
mom passed away
and I got blipped back
they rounded us to investigate
Earthbound anomalies Monica
how you feeling like myself
now I can manipulate wavelengths of the
electromagnetic spectrum I'm very happy
for you where's our daughter yes where
is come on
oh my God
how do you have this
my grandma sent it to me in the mail
have you ever wanted something so bad
and it actually happened
but it's not as great as you imagined it
you want to save the world
and You're Gonna Save the World
[Music]
tell me
what's happening we switch places
whenever we use our powers
oh
I'm tired further faster
together
[Music]